for people that aren't familiar with the
holly boob give us a quick rundown on
what that was about oh we
pulled it up austin we gave the
hollywood sign a boob job
hell yeah that's what i'll say
everyone in la's got a boob job we
figured we just you know help the town
out a little bit and
turn it into the holly boobs just
changed it recently for uh yeah ram's
house it looks like [ __ ] i was gonna say
i saw that and i thought of you i was
like jack did this way back yeah yeah we
did better in like 20 minutes
what happened they did well they changed
it to let's go ranch it says ram's house
yeah but it was like barely even legible
yeah this is the raw footage and you got
a did you get arrested during this yeah
i still have community service because
of this section wow
that's my buddy ricky he was actually uh
he wasn't even supposed to
help with the holly boob prank he was
just coming out there to do a bigfoot
stunt with me
uh
oh this is a super bowl oh [ __ ] straight
to the super bowl a random super bowl
clip i have no idea
what it's a mashup
oh probably somebody else's page that
rich oh no this is your page is it
oh yeah you just decided to throw in
some i don't remember maybe
it was just oh that was just the intro i
was just talking about what was going on
in the future probably but this is yeah
this is like the raw footage of the
holly boob sign but
yeah i went to jail for this what did
they charge you with just trespassing
there's trespassing no vandalism huh no
vandalism no no because we didn't
actually do anything to the sign it was
just placed there we didn't like paint
on it or anything true yeah we got that
thing up there in a baby stroller like i
had to push a baby stroller up a
mountain with
that giant tarp the size of a body that
weighed like 100 pounds
that was the only way because we
actually tried this twice this was the
third attempt
we tried it twice in the middle of the
night and they got and like almost got
caught we were trying to sneak up the
mountain and uh they were shining lights
at us and they like brought in a
helicopter we all like scattered like
cockroaches she had to do during the day
yesterday we're like all right how we
had to rethink it we're like all right
we'll do it during the day broad
daylight we're gonna start from the top
and start at the bottom and just
rush it and try to do it quickly
wow yeah but on that topic like
i i don't worry about making content
because i feel like we've made so much
content that there's always going to be
people that are going to check back
because we're always like the best yet
to come you know we're always going to
keep making videos i feel like there's
just always going to be people that are
going to want to check back on what
we're doing whether it's a week from now
a month from now a year from now like i
think that we've established a pretty
core audience in everything that we've
done so
you know i always want to keep content
outflow out but i also have been really
wanting to focus on like bigger projects
like maybe doing a
stand-up routine or like buying land and
opening megalodon ranch and
allowing people to come hunt for sharks
teeth with us and
you know maybe make some documentaries i
have a couple
crazy ideas for documentaries just like
really yeah just
like documentaries that you would
release on your youtube page no i'd want
to um i'd want to like shop them on the
platforms like you know maybe get
something on netflix or
hulu whatever anybody who's interested
yeah
netflix is so crazy dude there's like
there's so many [ __ ] shows on netflix
it's almost impossible like how could
they there's so many [ __ ] like
long-form series on netflix that come
out every single day it's hard to keep
up with all of them they want content
though you know and they're a good place
to release content and they're actually
paying pretty well like if you're an
influencer that has like a really good
docu-series or documentary something
like that they'll actually pay you good
money to really release it on their
platform because you're going to be
bringing your fan base to their platform
do you know of anybody who's transfer
transitioned from youtube to netflix as
far as like career-wise or content-wise
uh sam macaroni he's the guy that
directed guest house that movie that i
was in he made youtube videos for a
really long time and now he's full-time
director
okay that's something i've always been
interested in too it's just like getting
into like shooting some
real content while everybody's out there
making 15 second tick tocks i want to
like learn the ropes of the film
industry and maybe like shoot some
really sick documentaries oh yeah like
like deckhands that [ __ ] was awesome you
know my favorite series that's my
favorite [ __ ] ever and like that's some
[ __ ] they easily could go on netflix
that people would enjoy you know yeah
like i've been going to mexico for 10
years straight like even talking about
turner like i feel like that's a crazy
documentary too like yeah
i don't think anyone
on the platform on youtube in history
has ever gone from 100 000 subscribers
to 10 million as quickly as turner did i
don't think it's ever happened no dude
it can't that was crazy he went so
nuclear so fast such a short amount of
time like world famous like yeah in one
year from being a kid that was playing
video games like in the back room of the
house you know it just i know didn't
even make sense like he didn't he didn't
care about anything like the crazy thing
i always tell people about him is just
like like a lot of people just try to
chase all the trends you know he did the
opposite of that
he did the opposite of that he stayed in
his room and he kept playing video games
and then one video game came came about
that just happened to be the kerosene to
the [ __ ] match but you just cannot
deny his [ __ ] skill too
so now it's like he just won in apex
legends uh i saw that rival's training
it was yesterday huge tournament he
doesn't play apex legends very often and
like
he certainly doesn't practice it at a
pro level you know and he's a there's a
clip that just went viral of um
yeah they're doing like the the
interview of the finals and they're like
asking him a question and he just
tornadoed a beer
on stream like on the twitch rivals like
live stream
yeah he's like talking [ __ ] too like
i don't understand how you can not play
the game like on a professional level
and not
his in-game iq yeah he just outsmarts
everyone it doesn't matter how
mechanical yeah you are he'll like he's
just smarter yeah i'll just do it he's
one step ahead of you
i think he's more like
60 steps ahead
i've watched you have you ever seen the
the pops of like his fingers when he's
playing yeah do you remember right
before he blew up like right right with
him i made that little video yeah the
little document ten minute documentary
it got millions of views now it has like
five million views yeah but that was
like right that was like the day i
uploaded that was like the day he
officially joined faze yeah
yeah they make it making florida look
bad do you ever like when they're from
florida do you ever like stress out
about like what kind of content you want
to make or like what types of videos you
want to make next or do you just kind of
just do whatever you want and
just like
film it and if it turns out good you
just decide to post it it's like yes and
no you know i always want to make really
good content but i don't stress it
because i feel like we've made
so much content over the years and like
we've
consistently in my opinion uploaded
really good content over the course of
like eight years you know like
even if we take a long break from doing
something like
you know in like the most comments that
i got about the jigsaw channel being
dead was
you like know when it was like right
before we did holly boop and like
there's all these people like oh you
guys are washed up you know like blah
blah this and that and like people are
gonna say everything you know and
it's hard to not focus on the bad
comments but once you
like take a break from uploading like
there's gonna be people that are gonna
talk a lot of [ __ ] and then we like do
the holly boob stunt and prank and pull
it off and it's like on every news
station and like getting millions of
views across all these different
platforms